volatile loner or hard-working
aspirational pupil as details of
mohammed emwazi the early life emerged
there are more questions about how an
ordinary young man from West London
ended up as a knife-wielding jihadist
now Sky News has spoken exclusively to a
teacher from Quinton coniston and was
he's former school she knew him and his
family when he was a pupil there she
asked that her identity be concealed he
didn't particularly stand out in any way
as with a number of young people growing
up he did have some issues when he was
younger and they were dealt with through
normal school interventions he was quite
successful academically and he went on
to do his a-levels at the school and the
focus was very much on preparing him for
life after school and university does
that resonate with you that he was
somebody who needed approval and was
quite easily influenced by others around
him I would describe him as vulnerable i
would also describe him as having low
self-esteem and therefore needing
reassurance that he was doing well with
his work but he did achieve well at the
school and there were plenty of signs
for him to be able to feel good about
himself but there are fears that
radicalization did begin at school the
Department for Education has said it's
reviewing evidence from mohamed emwazi
school from the time use of pupil there
and my sources have said that's part of
an intense intelligence gathering
exercise focusing on that and other
schools where pupils have gone to fight
abroad but in mahalena muahhh zzzz caves
it's not only what happened at school
that's prompting concern a fellow
student at westminster university where
a muahz he studied between 2006 and 2009
said there was a culture of
radicalization I wasn't shocked at all
when it turned out mohammed emwazi had
been a student at the university of
westminster in all honesty I'm surprised
a student from there before hadn't done
something like this I do you think the
university has failed here they didn't
take into consideration that extremists
were being invited onto campus to give
speeches on what appeared like a regular
basis some questions will never be
answered it's incomprehensible to me
that a young person who appeared to have
such a positive roots into adult life
could become the monster that he appears
to have become today and I keep asking
myself over and over
again why how did this happen what could
possibly have changed in his life to
have taken him down this path and I'm
not sure we will ever know the answer
mohammed emwazi smother has now said she
immediately recognized her son's voice
the first time she saw him in a hostage
video just a few years earlier it seems
the clues were simply not there
therefore Hirsch Sky News